Argentine beef is considered to be among
the best in the world but it's become
almost unaffordable for many people in
Argentina it has gone up by an average
of 35 percent in the past months Enrique
owns the shop in the province of Buenos
Aires
people come and ask for the cheapest
Cuts because that's all they can afford
and all I can give nothing is cheap the
situation is very complicated for
everyone this latest spike in prices
came after the government evaluated the
currency by around 20 percent Argentina
is already struggling with exchange rate
controls depleted foreign reserves and a
massive foreign debt a few weeks ago
looting began in several parts of
Argentina in lomera mosa Eduardo Lopez
decided to defend his property with a
shotgun and rubber bullets
I was not thinking to kill anyone I had
rubber bullets but it could also happen
that in the middle of the chaos someone
opens fire on the population
the growing threat of violence has
forced the government to increase cash
handouts and tax exemptions to lighten
the impact of economic hardship on the
population but few believe such
short-term measures will solve the real
problem
presidential elections are a little over
a month and a half away the government
has no plan and no political power to
carry out the policies needed to fight
inflation and that's why many of the
people you talk to in places like this
one are hoping that whomever wins the
presidency will be able to control the
situation
Argentina's inflation rate has been over
120 percent in the past year the figure
could continue to rise in the weeks
ahead when you have a major political
reform that will back up the value of a
currency
so for that to happen we need a new
government
we need a very credible plan we need to
have reserves in the central bank and we
need to bring down the budget deficit I
mean everybody
knows this from an economic point of
view now you need the political side and
the political credibility to do that
argentines are now looking to the
elections for Relief their choices range
from establishment candidates to radical
libertarian Economist Javier Miley now
the surprise front-runner
he's proposing radical measures to fix
the economy ideas that are increasingly
resonating among those who are tired of
the uncertainty they face every day that
is
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera